everything I've done in my life I've
done for my children I know I made
mistakes but I've always tried to do the
best by them because I love them maybe
you thought about the possibility that
your children are actually scared of you
oh off I want a broadcast network I
don't want to see what other news
operations we can sweep up local TV
nobody watches TV why shouldn't we do
all the news well Kim Jong pop because
that's not how things work in this
country we have a major problem he's
erratic he's making bad decisions if
he's not careful he's gonna destroy the
company Emel are you gonna do something
I think I'm the best option all right
cuz you like playing boss this is my
vision I take over you two under me
under you to me think about it
of course oh that's cute this family's
broken and that has consequences
pick out the old man in with the new
guard where you been I was meeting about
a prospective job with your father's
enemy disagree with dad is not treason
you want this enough to go to war with
your family
it's rebellion
sabotage the liberty attempt to
undermine my whole business that's the
death pit take a look and I feel like I
might not like it
in death pit stops crowd below 130 we
could deaths by earlier
who's in charge right now
that's my company you are a
nobody
[Music]
you